hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
um you're almost there
it's Thursday do you even have to say
that to people anymore you're almost
there who's kid new
you never went back to the office after
[__] covid you're working from home I
don't want to go in there and guess what
they don't want to see you
they don't want to see your [__] sad
face they know what they're doing to you
they know how much they're undervaluing
you and underpaying you and all of that
[__]
um you should be at home tell you what
I'll come in when you [__] give me a
wage that can keep up with these gas
prices the [__] bidens America on my
right
[__] dummies
yeah that's that's what's driving the
gas prices up it's it's that it's not
the uh the collusion between the oil
companies and the Federal Reserve
printing money with no gold behind it no
it's not that it's it's that guy
and not because he's an idiot because
he's an idiot with a blue tie and I like
idiots with red ties that's how I do
politics everybody guess who's on the
podcast it's beep beep the lovely Nia
hello oh hello
story shout out to nickroll and John
Mulaney oh hello oh hello
um I gotta see John mulaney's new
stand-up special her it's [__]
unbelievable unbelievable
um so anyway
um
I saw this story in the New York Post
because I'm an old man I still buy
newspapers I go out and I get a cup of
coffee and I go oh would you look at
this a cup of joe yep I sit there by
myself and then I talk to other people
at tables who don't want I insert myself
yeah can you believe what's going on
with the water company
you know they're going to dig up the
street I mean that's gonna be a mess
um listen you're 55 years old so you
read newspapers at coffee shops and
complain about
you know everything yeah I love it Oh
Billy with his blue tie red tie oh boy
here we go again
you both suck wow Bill wow
but they're still doing it though
doing it yeah they're still doing it
you're still doing it too so how long
we're gonna have to listen to you right
when they stop when they stop okay so
not for a while huh that's what he's
saying it's pointless I do I do think
it's pointless okay well then okay okay
if we're gonna go the pointless route
okay we're gonna go the place
when are those women on the shows you
watch gonna get along
all of them literally everything that I
watched
It's never gonna happen yeah but you
don't hear me complaining about it
damn it
so you just don't care that they don't
get along all right I guess I shouldn't
care that the whole country's going down
the [__] all right fine
all right with that happy thought
so my old ass I'm watching I'm reading
the uh the newspaper
and
um
they did this article right this I this
woman wrote this article
talking about how there was these two
twins that played for the University of
Miami they played basketball Division
One okay okay so I don't give a [__]
even if you're coming off the bench you
can play one was averaging 15 points a
game
which I mean I don't what do they score
in college 50 60 points that's a lot of
points in her twin sister was getting
four points a game so there was this big
thing about colleges making money off of
athletes images okay
and now they somehow the athletes have
won the right to actually make money on
what they look like so
these two twins
beautiful blondes they start taking
pictures of themselves in bikinis and
whatnot and
right and growing their followers yeah
and they made two million bucks oh good
for them thank you this woman wrote this
because it should be more about their
skills and not their minds because
they're well yeah that was her point
they're going like they made all this
money because they're pretty so and so
you know averaged 25 points a game and
blah blah blah blah but she stopped
short of saying she wasn't as good
looking but that's what she was saying
that was the implication is that the
person that's really the the
a skilled athlete athlete yeah athlete
yep
um is not getting the recognition
because they're not exploiting their
good looks
how are you exploiting your looks if
you're making money
yeah I mean they have age
themselves they know what's gonna work
and they're twins and they're both
beautiful and they both are Athletics so
I'm sure they have great bodies and so
they're just kind of yeah like playing
the game and they're they're profiting
off of it which I feel like this is what
we this is what we're uh I don't know if
we're supposed to be doing but if that's
what they want to do then they should do
it yeah so I just kind of thought it was
interesting that they kind of came out
and first of all she acts like they're
playing on like playing at the
University of Miami
playing women's basketball like they
didn't have to beat out a bunch of
people to do it they she acted like it
wasn't division one this one went back
to like Anna Kournikova who was smoking
hot
and you're the tennis girl oh my God she
was gorgeous the most beautiful women in
the world right and she was and and was
like the eighth ranked
woman
in professional tennis she never won a
major but she played in him she could
have just been the [__] hottie trying
to get a free [__] zambuka at the
local [__] bar
she played tennis and we came whatever
the [__] it is sambuca whatever it is
she got she became the eighth ranked
tennis player in the world and that was
all out the [__] window because you
know she didn't win like a major and
didn't do the whole thing I just think
all of that [__] [__] is like it's
always comes from women who aren't as
pretty as he obviously is the woman that
they're complaining about and then it
also comes from guys that feel like they
can't get beautiful women they're
[__] beautiful if they can make money
off of it they didn't set up the deal
that's how the deal works so they're
playing the game
I just I gotta be honest is a
card-carrying misogynist like it was
great to see this woman write this
article and take down those two women
are you officially a card carrying yes
okay so after I have my cup of coffee
and you know read my newspaper yeah and
talk about the water company okay
I go around the corner and uh you know
it's me and a bunch of other [__]
idiots I don't know I don't know what
I'm talking about but
I I just I don't understand why why
can't they you know they look good in a
bikini why can't you go make money doing
that I
sure in place in terms of you know the
patriarchy that's a bigger conversation
that's really what she's getting at
I don't think she was she was talking
about beauty well I want to read I want
to read the article
wait is this somehow going to come down
that men [__] up here this is like
literally woman on woman crime here
I'm sure she was talking about something
bigger than what you've distilled it
down to well that was wrong wow that was
very condescending wow I mean wow all
right Nia Renee Hill everybody okay
thank you for stopping by Jesus Christ
I'm the one I'm supporting those two
[__] people that win two million they
make 200 million dollars right
twenty [__] [__] whatever they're
doing
because I was trying not to say broads I
was supporting those two broads
whatever
all right I mean okay I guess I guess
it's just it's just [__] you know
something I have to be honest with you
that is the thing that [__] annoys
the [__] out of me
about women where it's just like when
it's
when it's the guy's fault it's our fault
and when it's your fault it's still our
fault
how do you grow
I mean that's the question for you ask
your fellow brethren
that I have to like somehow figure out
why a woman would take two other women
down who made two million dollars who
are being exploited exploited by the
patriarchy whatever the [__] that means
right the university and they figured
out a way to make it they figured out a
way to make two million bucks
and then somehow that's my fault and I
need to do work what about the lady that
wrote the article I want to read it
but maybe she's got some bias against
you you want to read it
to give her the benefit of the doubt
should I be giving you the benefit of
the doubt evidently not because
I should give you the benefit of the
doubt about when a woman speaks about
what women are going through I should
give you the benefit of the doubt no I
just think it's interesting
yeah but you didn't give me the benefit
of that laminated massaging this card
can you know put that in your little
pipe and smoke it how about that
you didn't give me the benefits of the
doubt you immediately thought that I was
being a [__] idiot and there's a
thing I did thank you can I ask you a
question if you go read this are you
gonna do like a page 90 retraction of
your comments on me like how they always
do in the newspaper perhaps I will in a
very small print at the very bottom
[Laughter]
I just I okay you know what this really
Taps into it really has nothing to do
with
like that misogyny [__] what it has to
do is I just [__] hate people that
just [__] stop there
[Laughter]
you were destroying me there's really no
need to go any further
all right all right forget it forget it
forget it
forget it whoa whoa be back it's great
to be back so what do you want to talk
about I don't know what do you want are
we going to talk about didn't you
already mention something that we we
went through are we going to talk about
that no I don't feel like talking about
that okay I just don't because of the
patriarchy that owns that hill and I'm
sure big pharmaceutical bought the
[__] mushrooms and blah blah blah
blah Nia I [__] can't stand people
that hate on somebody because they have
something that they don't have because
they're better looking than them because
they're taller because they have more
money because they came I just it's just
not a good [__] look and you don't
grow and like
you know it's like okay so that you
weren't dealt that hand you were dealt a
hand play the [__] hand and quit your
[__] whining and quit trying to dumb
the whole game down to your [__]
level so you can win
figure out how to [__] win what's
wrong with that is that misogynistic
there's nothing wrong with that all
right that's all the [__] I was trying
to say I mean
well why don't we just stop it right
there
there's a few other things that you're
not considering in that statement but
for yes but what overall I didn't mean
it racially I'm not
talking oh all right neighbors track
that
can I bro
that's me rewinding it
well then what else why are you talking
about oh man this is getting good what
else were you talking about then
oh just then oh I mean because you had a
it was a very like pull yourself up by
your bootstraps type of vibe
there's nothing wrong with that
statement when applied correctly okay
and I'm not saying I'm not talking about
uh
uh in in in terms of like male female
race homophobia none of that [__]
okay there is a time where you have to
quit [__] whining about your goddamn
Stitch we're talking about looks here
yes talk about practice something about
looks here what was that a reference to
just now Allen Iverson okay
um
you play for the 76ers I know he's a
basketball player okay all right okay
he's right anyway I'm just saying you
it's like me being upset that more women
find Ryan Gosling attractive
than me I mean exactly
you're married to me and you laughed and
it is ridiculous right it's ridiculous
why would I ever do that and why would I
try to like [__] dumb the whole thing
down that people have to look at me the
way they're looking at that guy right
because it's just not gonna happen it
isn't
it
you're being such a dick you're just
being a dick oh I thought I was having
fun isn't this fun
no it is you know why because I was
having one of those days I'm gonna talk
to the fans now oh okay if there's if I
have any left it's you know like when
you wake up you wake up and you love the
other person more than they're loving
you and it makes it makes you feel
stupid you're already you're already
morning with the arm rub that's what it
is so I was yeah I am I have feelings
too I know you do no no no that's okay
it's okay we'll leave it at that yeah
we'll leave it at that
we'll leave it with that because I'm not
gonna go any further into this because
somehow
by the end of this this is gonna be my
fault so just no no no no [__] the whole
thing [__] the whole thing talk about it
no no I'm just gonna go down to the
local pub get myself a coffee in a
newspaper and talk about the water
company
that's what I'm gonna do
huh can I join you no no you're not
gonna cue your way into this the way you
always do
[Music]
if that went the other way you'd be like
did I [__] do something and then I'd
have to deal with that for like 36 hours
of you walking around doing that [__]
uh I literally took you to and from the
[__] gym and you were still and you
were still a jerk to me I wasn't
Insurance to you I didn't say anything I
was just driving a whole provisionist
history
everybody's over to caress my arm it was
very sweet and I just I don't know I had
was a little distracted and I just
wasn't into that hey guys if you're not
into it and it put away then maybe you
should take a [__] a [__] clue
right than the exact same thing hey guys
when a woman reach out to you maybe you
should [__] acknowledge it she's got
through this too that's how you're right
that's how it works and I'm sorry that I
did yeah I'm gonna tell you right now
you can take that you can wrap it up on
a go [__] yourself package send it DSL
or whatever that bootleg [__] fennel
expresses DHL you can send it that in
whatever color their trucks are because
no one ever sees them red and yellow red
and yellow red and yellow all right
mustard and ketchup colored that's right
all right well knowledge you have
feelings and I'm sorry that I I pulled
it's too late it's too late I took
mushrooms I got the German Irish walled
off [__] out of me and you've brought it
all back I'm right I'm right back to it
I'm right back to it all right
yeah go ahead you can talk about it
a little bit you know I got an idea why
don't you talk about it okay okay so
then I won't have to [__] deal with
you coming at me
I mean this is really bizarre like I I
took you to and from your workout we
went over we went to the PO box
everything was [__] great we had a
nice lunch together yeah okay all right
all right
okay
no we're good are we yes we're fine all
right
this wasn't feeling
um I know but but there was a pre there
was other [__] that happened in our
relationship before that so I just
wasn't know if that was like [__]
lingering no and you know no not the the
10-day silent punishment for the
three-minute error no that's never it's
never that there's no eye contact right
now there's no eye contact whatever
okay
so what are you what are we talking
about on this podcast
um well certainly not women in bikinis
making two million dollars
which I'm all for
I was too yeah I know you are okay
I find that you're half right A lot of
the times
I'll take that
you don't even feel like and I feel like
you're like a cat
where if I come to you you're like get
the [__] away from me and if I ignore
you you're like what's going on with you
and it's [__] annoying
so it's like it's literally like if I
want affection from you I have to walk
away from you it's so [__] immature
like all you [__] broads get into
that Beyonce mode when a guy steps to
him like can't get this big My milkshake
brings all that dumb [__] right
oh you [__]
don't don't even try oh yeah all that
Diva [__] yeah because in your heart
like I feel like a guy and and a guy's
heart of hearts he really wants to be
that guy in an action movie with the
cool car he knows how to fight he knows
how to operate every [__] piece of
Machinery whatever sort of style you
come in hanging from smoking hot women
he's banging him but he's not really
emotionally attached but they're hanging
all over his sweaty [__] biceps right
we all want to be that guy and I think
you guys all want to be like
keep dreaming baby you know
I think that's what it is so when you
don't walk up to my Trans Am that I
don't even have with the t-tops it
bothers me and uh when I don't I don't
know I think I I think I I tell you
you're beautiful enough I do get your
[__] hand off of me
it's over oh
man
um talk about the mushroom trip and
where we were and evidently not there
anymore
my favorite thing you said my favorite
thing you said after well I know it's
still there but my favorite thing you
said you said after the mushroom trip is
you go
you go was that true did that really
happen or were we just two idiots on
mushrooms and I go it was both
that really did happen so we
and I'm gonna do like a little something
on my Instagram about not this part this
will just be for the podcast but yeah so
we went someplace and we had mushrooms
and it was like it was my first time
really taking mushrooms and especially
in my first time taking it in the Raw
and it was my first time really having
like a an adequate dose that would bring
certain things out so you know I had
heard that we need to have it onto an
empty stomach so we took it at 9 30 in
the morning all we had was water and
that [__] metabolized like that and 20
minutes later real fast real fast real
fast and furious and then we were
thinking we were gonna go on a nature
walk no no no no no no realized you you
were thinking that was your idea let's
go and walk through nature and I was
like going I don't know that we want to
do that I think we want to be here
sensation on a spider but I was like
look at that
look at that I know and then I was
thinking like all right we took it yeah
we took an equal dose but I think
because you're smaller you went a little
further but like yeah so when we we went
back to no no no you missed it we we
walked and we went to go into that
they'll get on that trail and it was
like 12 signs saying we shoot guns here
we got guns there's guns did we mention
there's guns there's nothing there's
nothing here worth dying over
yep and we were like all right you know
I see those signs like yep I hear what
they're saying maybe we won't be
God forbid yeah so then we were like
walking back up the hill and we was like
a dirt driveway we were staying in this
uh
you know there was nobody around
whatever you say that rural yeah so
um and we Overlook in the ocean and all
that we were up in the hills and
um
I remember we got like halfway up the
driveway and you just stopped
and you were looking up at the clouds oh
my God and your mouth was just hanging
open as you was smiling you're like oh
calling me and I was just like oh my God
and I wanted to start laughing but I
didn't want to ruin your trip but I was
I was so happy for you I was like oh my
God and I also saw I knew that you were
having a good trip yeah so you were you
you look like you were literally
tripping you were just looking at the
clouds whatever the [__] they were doing
and mine hadn't hit me like that yet so
my whole thing was I was just trying to
be a calm Force to get you back to the
base camp yes which was the move it was
a hundred percent yeah thank God
a few minutes after that moment
I could not have been in the middle like
when we didn't really know where we were
we were just walking like oh we're just
looking at the power it's like I had my
little oh everything is Wavy Gravy and
like the hills were alive with the sound
of music and things were undulating
colors were popping like literally like
every like the hills were moving it was
that and then we were both lying down on
these like lounge chairs I had gotten us
blankets where we said the whole thing
up we're both lying there like like
under our blankets just chilling out
yeah cracking up laughing having a good
time and then you and then all of a
sudden yeah and she was underneath the
covers and she just looks over she just
goes and she has her sunglasses on a hat
on and the covers pulled up over her
nose underneath her sunglasses
and you just go baby
I'm like what you're like I have to ask
the universe a question
and I'm like well it's your Universe too
you know right ask the question yeah so
then you you as you were asking the
question I was thinking to myself a
person that's in my life that's a
narcissist I was like they should take
this [__]
because I think it would maybe would
help them because narcissists they can't
help themselves it's really a sad thing
to watch
and then I was thinking like what would
a narcissist on mushrooms ask the
universe and I thought in my head The
Narcissist would say to the universe
what do you want to know
and it was a dumb joke so I start
cracking up laughing and then you ask
the universe whatever you asked it I
don't even think
s that a question I just my there was a
part of my mind my brain whatever my
soul whatever that was became open to
receiving whatever it was that the
Universe wanted to tell me so that's
really [__] heavy man it wasn't as if
I was even asking a specific question
like you would ask like a fortune teller
or a psychic or something like that it's
just something in my brain opened up and
then I received this message that said
you are a lonely goddess walking the
Earth and from that moment on everything
changed oh yeah like meaning you started
sobbing I went back I don't know how
much you wanted
out to my most low
parents are divorced I had to fly back
and forth over the Summers to see my dad
here in La I grew up in Atlanta I'm from
Boston grew up in Atlanta but I would
fly back to see my dad who moved out
here when I was like eight right so I
went back to that low like what I recall
being like the loneliest moment of just
dealing with the back and forth and not
really having somebody there to like
sort of talk to about things because you
know it was like back then it was just
like go see your dad there and it was no
talking about it how are you doing are
you okay I know you know it must be hard
none of that stuff so I went back to
that moment as a child I was literally
holding myself as that child
comforting her sobbing weeping
and telling her it was gonna be okay
everything was going to be fine but that
I couldn't keep coming back there I had
to move forward I had to move on I can't
you know keep staying in that lonely
place and I had to embrace being the
Goddess that is here to lead with like
love and empathy and fun and excitement
that was the message and meanwhile I was
laying
on the thing and I was waving at the
clouds and you asked me later I guess
and you're like what were you waving at
and well the clouds had all turned into
like these skulls they look like
skeletons to me too yeah that were kind
of coming to get me and I knew what they
were I was like those are my demons I
know I have them I'm not afraid of them
so I just was like Hey guys
good to see you again and the second I
waved at him this other Cloud came in
like it was on a horse with like a
[__] sword and just stabbed one in
his his mouth just kept opening until it
like disappeared and then after that I
was like fine
and um
no just watching all your stuff I I told
you sort of I guess I was joking about
the misogyny it kind of cured me of my
misogyny because I've been telling you
since the day I met you
I was like you're a goddess I've been
telling you that it's true he that's
that's always the compliment he gives me
and so so I'm sitting here
weeping and sobbing for my lonely child
and my lonely childhood and but then I
you know then the Euphoria kicked in and
I was like oh my God like I know what it
is now like I know what it is I have
been struggling with because I think
about when I was a kid and I you know
had so much but I would often feel so
sad and I was like and I remember
thinking why am I sad right now like
what's making me sad and I think it was
the loneliness of being a child of
divorce and even though my parents
divorced when I was like two and a half
three years old
and I don't have any memories of it I
still was very lonely in my journey
between them and they never talk [__]
about each other they never put me in
the middle they were very mature I had a
great relationship with my Dad we were
in communication all the time but that
that journey of going from Atlanta to La
every summer I think was very lonely for
me to leave all my friends in Atlanta
and then go to La and kind of have to
make new friends or reconnect with the
friends that I saw last summer that I
haven't seen all year and so much when
your kids so much happens in the school
year you know you change so much so to
have to go
and sort of start over every single time
I think was lonely for me and even
though I don't really have memories of
all of us together I have pictures of
when I'm a baby and there's the three of
us but I don't know that life and so
there's something very lonely about that
too so to be able to finally like give
it a name of the whatever it is that
I've been holding on to and struggle
with even in like adulthood feeling like
lonely on this journey of life or
whatever that when when that came to me
it was like oh my God this is what it is
you know so yes I was weeping and
sobbing uncontrollably and you were
right there with me like consoling me
and you know all that other stuff and it
took you through the trip man yeah yeah
it was it was it was really great I
thought we really had an amazing moment
you know
right yeah no it did it's just me no no
no I just I don't know how much you want
to talk about it but yeah it was great I
ain't gonna get in at all no we
basically we left we sobbed we told each
other we loved each other we said we
were soul mates we had a great time
because it could have gone the other way
we could have had a trip and been like
what the [__] have I been doing with you
imagine like but we both were like
inside like saying all these things that
we needed to say to each other and like
loving on each other and giving each
other all these compliments and like it
was not
should we be together I don't know it
was we were very much
like yes and then we drove down the hill
afterwards got something to eat and then
we realized and then it does like like
what the [__] is that
whoa that really [__] happened like
it was honestly I will never be the same
that was a transformative experience and
yeah there's stuff that we said to each
other is gonna remain with us but uh
and then at the end of the night at dusk
um
I was in my truck with the lovely Nia
and uh Nia loves the ocean so I just
backed it up in this parking spot we sat
in the tailgate and watched people surf
it was so beautiful it was so great it
was such a [__] amazing trip
literally figuratively yeah and then
what's funny is then the second it's
it's over then we were coming down to
the hills down onto the [__] 118 or
the 101 whatever the [__] we were and it
was like and back into the Matrix yeah
oh my God yeah 100 and I was kind of
like I felt a little depressed I just
feel like you know you get that dopamine
or serotonin or whatever it is you get
that rush you get that high and then you
kind of come down and you're just sort
of like that's why I was like was that
real that happened was that true no but
that's why it's just like a high idiot
like just you know and you were like no
it was real but yes we were also
no but what I like about them is it
doesn't make me want to go and just
start like I smoke a cigar and then the
next day I was like I want another cigar
and I gotta fight smoking another one
you know it's not like that it's
actually you come down and for me anyway
and then it's like I need to work on
this part of my life I need to work on
that part of my life yeah and that's how
I feel and then it's just like all right
and then in like you know a year or so
I'll take them again I'll check in on
them because like
I don't think um
you know going around like if I like
micro dose those things and I'm just
sort of and everything's groovy man like
all the time I don't have like
depression like like people like walk
around like like clinically depressed or
something like that I heard it's really
helpful for that but I I know the micro
dosing and I find it like super helpful
but I don't feel like that's what the
[__] been going on with you no I don't
feel like weird I don't feel weird I
don't feel high I feel incredibly clear
and focused but I also don't take it
every day I take it Monday through
Thursday and then I take a break as
instructed by the person who's guiding
me through that type of thing so I don't
know for me for me I feel very
productive on the days that I'm on it I
don't feel like not productive on the
off days but on the on days I feel
extremely productive and very like
keated why are you laughing I'll just
picture you you're actually doing like
some pill version of cocaine and you're
like grinding I'm [__] getting [__]
done no no no no no no it's because I I
came up I came up in the era of like I
feel like this is like a golden age of
drugs where like uh as far as like
the ones that are like illegal in a way
they made weed is now legal but like
mushrooms for the most part are still
illegal I think although that seems to
be changing which I think is gonna be a
bad thing for mushrooms because once
corporations get their hands on it like
you look at weed now I mean those
gummies and stuff with all that sugar
all over them it's like what did you
turn this into yeah you know and and I I
worry that they're gonna do that and
then somehow the Monsanto will own the
seed
the Monsanto whatever the [__] are they
they were they're the guy that took over
the whole [__] food supply oh and if
there's seeds blew onto your Farmland
they could sue you for using them
because of the wind oh my God oh my God
yeah okay if you ever listen to John
Cougar Mellencamp singing about that
stuff
never listen John Cougar Mellencamp so
anyway
there's a sequel to Jack and Dan yeah
what's it what's it called Jack and
Diane and Fran
[Music]
well they opened up their relationship
yeah oh my God because they got they got
bored they got bored with each other and
they tried that and they just didn't
realize that they just it was a young
love and it wasn't real oh
the seven minute song
it was a b side
on the 45 to uh smoke and fire whatever
that song was
like heaven and fire whatever that one
is
I don't know I'm not familiar with this
catalog something and something I saw
him one time not minoration oh my
no he passed away on a motor he had a
motorcycle accident oh where was he
on a motorcycle no I mean where I like
wear geographically I don't know
I not to bring the podcast down but it
totally broke down especially because I
was I was going to book myself
in this part of the country where uh I
know a guy D knows a guy that [__]
has access to motorcycles like I'll
write them out here I know I will but
you also know how I feel about you doing
so I won't do it I want you to yes
please I want you to like put
T around with with my newspaper my
coffee yes that's what I want
to be nervous that's awesome well this
will go
this is the conundrum I now have after
my
my uh
when I was tripping I was watching you
and all of that so like I've always
viewed you as a goddess and I always
felt like you would you were a
higher being in that the way you uh like
I've never met somebody that like roots
for people
the way you do even if you're currently
struggling you still root for people and
are genuinely happy for them if
something good happens to them which is
very rare
and what I thought was part of the thing
where it said you're a lonely God is
part of that is when you are living as a
higher being there is a loneliness to
that because you're just looking at
people hurting each other as you're
thinking like it doesn't have to be like
this right
so
I was sitting there thinking about my
behavior and looking at you and seeing
you finally verbalize that you are a
goddess I started thinking about all of
the [__] horrible
[__] that I say about women and all that
and it's sort of it
you know it was cured my misogyny well
I'm not like you know I'm this weird
misogynist in that like you guys as a
group annoy the [__] [__] out of me
but as an individual I will help you
I'll go out of my way I will go out of
my way to help a woman it's you guys as
a [__] group when you get going and
start bitching like I cannot get out of
the room fast enough honestly I feel
like that's how women feel about men
like
a one-on-one like we I mean we love you
we want to care for you we don't want to
let's do a bunch of guys but like we
don't like to we don't to deal with a
bunch of you yeah well you gotta box
them out
women that like that Vibe they like that
energy that sports bar energy uh I do
not
um you know but I feel like that's
something those also the ones that tie
off their t-shirts
generally you guys do where it's like a
bunch of you together absolutely the
[__] not one-on-one the ones that I'm
interested in the ones that are cool
that are nice yes I'm all about it let's
connect you know but yeah so I'm
definitely speaking so without you can
you [__] kick rocks right so when I
was high on the mushrooms I'm sitting
there going like yeah like women are
goddesses I have to look at them like
that and then I drove down the mountain
into the Matrix you're like nope no
there's not enough of you vibrating on a
plane yeah
yeah you're not elevated so but if that
doesn't mean I gotta go around being the
the idiot then but I will say a lot of a
lot of this [__]
um
you know I'm a dick so like a lot of the
[__] that I I I do say is to get you
going yes you
I'm a [__] idiot who's going on tour
people oh nice Segway nice segue I will
be in Allentown Pennsylvania yeah I'm
doing all these blue-collar towns that
Bruce and Billy Joel sing about right
I'm going to Allentown
and they worked on the docks and they
get around
they set out Jesus Christ did this rust
out too
um and my dad had Polio during World War
II there is a group of
life together because I feel like you
obviously have mostly a lot of male fans
like I want like 10 of them to go to a
show and like five of them be wearing
red ties and five of them were wearing
blue ties and just be in the front
no that would I no but no what was I
going to do with that I don't know
I'm trying to get people to get past the
parties and stop acting like history
starts
like they're talking about in the
country is bankrupt it's it's been
bankrupt it's been bankrupt since we had
this never-ending [__] War that's
been costing us all this [__] money
into the point there's like people
forget we're even at War
like this is insane and every August
they had to print all this extra money
or we were literally going to go under
and now that happens in June so it's
like when is this gonna it's gonna back
all the way to January and then it
finally [__] collapses it's like
serious
[__] that is happening that is is not
talked like it like none of it is talked
about but then you just watch people
absolutely lose their [__] minds and
write an article in a major paper about
two chicks in a bikini that made two
million dollars
that was in the front section of the
[__] paper and then the Stu and then
the stupid Donald Trump media circus
over like this is the rich guy we're
gonna hold accountable
77th birthday yeah it's so stupid and
the precedent that they are starting now
for a president to use the Department of
Justice as a way to go after somebody of
a different political party is is beyond
uh the documents and the and and whatnot
and how he was spending his campaign
money and things like this what
president could you not do that to
what's that I said what president could
you not do that to
oh I don't know oh what are you
suggesting that they all do it uh like
they're filthy the only way you get that
job is to be filthy
they're not going to have some squeaky
clean person in there that is actually
gonna drink drain the swamp the it's
okay
it's all of those [__] guys Nia if
you look at the con everybody in
Congress and in the Senate they make a
couple hundred grand a year they're all
multi-fucking millionaires every [__]
one of them right okay they're grossly
underpaid yet they're worth millions of
dollars and everything they touch in the
private sector turns to [__] gold
these corporations Finance them they're
they're underpaid to be bribed by what
it used to be was Robert Barron's that
have now turned into these nameless
faceless corporations and these are the
same ones that when you ask them why
they're not doing the right thing they
blame their shareholders going well
because of the pressures of our
shareholders and we have to make profits
but then when they turn around and they
give themselves a 250 million dollar
bonus out of shareholder [__] money
they're just stealing it and for some
reason shareholders never say anything
then it's I'm saying the whole system is
100 it's 100 corrupt and then all of
these presidents when they [__]
retire they then go on the speech tour
and they make 300 Grand a night to go
thousand points of light and all of this
[__] [__] who do they give speech to
they go out to the corporations that put
them in office and then they then
incorporate gangs and then they pay them
300 Grand they're just washing their
bribe money and that's how they get
their money in their house on Martha's
Vineyard that's what the [__] I'm
talking about so people sit there and
the [__] that they say of you know of
like there was no Wars when Trump was
President it's like there's been a
never-ending War since George W bush
like what are you talking about what the
[__] are you talking about
if you're going to talk about this
country being bankrupt you got to go
back to to the the beginning the Federal
Reserve right through these [__] Wars
that we're having for profit that's
what's taken us out not not the evil
[__] Donald Trump not the forgetful
Joe Biden that the ship had already
[__] sailed
am I am I a crazy person
and all of these [__] people that
want to amass all these guns to fight
against a tyrannical government it's a
what are you waiting for and B the
second they figured out how to put a
machine gun on a biplane your gun
collection it was was [__]
neutralized
no I don't know whatever we had a good
mushroom trip everybody
[Laughter]
let me do some reads here
no I just I I don't understand why
people can't [__] see that it just
drives me up the [__] wall
and and I blame God Nia I blame God
we'll address that on our next one all
right yeah because he doesn't get any
[__] [__] what's forever for the
amount of mouth breathing [__] morons
who believe racist [__] and and and dumb
stuff all right Helix everybody
it's Helix sleep
he looks just like what the [__] ah they
they they know me I'm I got to be
selling something you know what's funny
I don't even know what they self I've
been reading this for [__] ever oh my
God mattresses Helix lineup offers 20
uniques
mattresses including the award-winning
Lux collection the newly released Helix
Elite collection a mattress designed for
Big and Tall sleepers and even a
mattress made just for kids so how will
does it come with a [__] seat belt so
they don't get out at three in the
morning so how will you know which Helix
mattress works for you and your body
take the Helix sleep quiz and find your
perfect mattress in under two minutes
everyone is unique Nia everybody and
everyone sleeps differently and that
should be okay that's why Helix has
several different mattress models to
choose from each designed for specific
sleep positions and feel preferences
feel like for me this mattress doesn't
work models and memory foam layers to
provide optimal pressure relief if you
sleep on your side you bought a new
[__] bed Neil we got to get one of
these mattresses oh I need to follow up
on that yeah you do
models with a more responsible foam to
cradle your body Nia for essential
support in the stomach in other areas
plus enhanced cooling features to keep
you from overheating at night
there's nothing funny than somebody
sweating their ass off sleeping that's
the worst that's happened to me it's
weird some nights it just happens I wear
the exact same pajamas right yes and
some nights it's [__] great another
and it's like it's not sometimes you
wake up and it's that that James Brown
video
government
and sweat it out all right plus enhanced
cooling features to keep you from
overheating at night don't want to take
my word for it Helix has been awarded
the number one mattress pick by GQ and
wide magazine it's even recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution improving your sleeps Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now what the hell like snia all
right
um stamps.com
why did I hit stop there stamps.com
everybody
um with so much of our world digitizer
automated why stick to Old School
mailing and shipping if you mail a
shipped often let stamps.com do the hard
part for you postage rates just
increased again luckily stamps.com has
the best discounts in the industry get
asked access to the USPS and UPS
Services you need right from your
computer anytime day or night no lines
no traffic no waiting stamps.com has a
long-standing relationship with USPS and
ups and they are able to pass on Amazing
rates to you up to 84 percent off with
stamps.com all you need is a computer
and printer they even send you a free
scale so you'll have everything you need
to get started if you need a package
pickup you can easily schedule it
through your stamps.com dashboard and if
you sell products online stamps.com
seamlessly connects with every major
Marketplace and shopping cart avoid the
hassle man and get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code Burr for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
digital Postage and free digital scale
no long-term commitments just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and enter the
code Burr that is the podcast everybody
enjoy the wonderful music picked out by
the ever talented Andrew thermalis and
enjoy an a bonus episode of the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
June 15th
2015 and I'm back in the United States
oh United States
of America
and Dennis
pigs in a blanket yeah I'm back I'm back
in the United States and uh immediately
I started putting on weight when I got
back here because there's something I
don't want the [__] is going on with
their food
you know you remember a long time ago
they had that book you know eat like uh
why eat like a French woman be a skinny
[__] [__] like the uh [__] chick
over there in Paris whatever whatever
was called
the secrets of being a skinny [__] in
Paris when uh you're Drinking Your Juice
in the Hood whatever the [__]
whatever the book was called
it has nothing to do with it their food
is is of a finer quality
and uh you know they're constantly
having legal battles with who's those
[__] evil [__]
what the [__] is their name the people
who own the food
you know monosant or something like that
ah Jesus Christ shouldn't I know this
Monsanto
hey [__] mom Tony Monsanto he owns
all the [__] Sage over here
um
yeah they're constantly fighting them
being like look if you want to have your
[__] genetically altered food over
here you have to put it on the label
that it's genetically altered and these
[__] won't [__] do it evidently
allegedly that's what I'm hearing
um I'm also hearing that they they sue
organic farmers like they [__] plant
their food next to uh
you know at the property next door to
the organic farmers and then when the
bees like cross pollinate then they sue
the [__] organic Farmer for [__]
having some of their uh I don't know
some of their [__] in their food I don't
even get how that works it's like well
when some of my organic stuff being some
of yours this is like a Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup here
but they're bigger so they sue them and
then they [__] win so anyways all I
know
is um if I really have to watch what I
eat in my own country and it's sad
because I want to eat like a [__]
animal like I did overseas you know and
I can still walk around and be a skinny
[__] in Paris while drinking the juice
in my hood
is that asking too much God bless
America
land that I love
you know those people like talk their
way through a song because they can't
sing anymore stand beside her
and guide her
through the light with the night up
above the band's still playing like that
front a mountain
do the prairies
to the honest
about
God Bless America
um you know he's throwing a little
vibrato at some point um
I'm in a dumb ass mood I'm still a
little jet lagged it's 453 where I'm at
right now I'm probably gonna wake up my
neighbors because when you live in LA
this you're that close
you're that close to your neighbor so
right now my next door neighbor she's
probably lying there going like who the
[__] is talk singing God Bless America
53 in the morning
I know my wife watches that show with
the ladies there whose dad is now a
woman
and you know the ones out there in
calabatha you know the way they [__]
talk I was sitting there
you know and this is this was a pivotal
turning point in me getting along better
with my wife was I just gave into
reality TV and I you know what I mean
I just dialed into my [__] inner
Caitlyn Jenner and was just like all
right I'm gonna [__] I'll feminine it
up here right
I'll tuck the package between the
[__]
I'll duck take my balls and dick to my
tank for the next [__] hour and I
will sit here and I will watch this
horseshit
so I'm watching it right
and uh the big one there
as Jay lawhead calls her the power
forward of the Kardashians
all right she's driving
the meerkat one and then the one who's
married to the [__] uh Kanye West
they always humble Kanye West right
and uh they're driving over because
she's trying to figure out you know
if the [__] whatever if the splooge
made it to the [__]
Hangar area sorry I'm not trying to get
on medical and you guys he's trying to
see if she's pregnant or what the [__]
going on instead of driving us some SUV
they're in Wyoming right because that's
what rich people in California do they
eventually you know want to pretend that
they're ranchers so they buy a big they
buy a spread out there in Montana or
something long and long start they're
driving in this [__] SUV
right the power forwards behind the
wheels j-lawhead calls her the meerkat
is in the [__] passenger seat and uh
old splooges in the back right
so
they [__] uh
it's snowing
and this truck goes by you know the
truck has like the wind or whatever you
know as it goes by
so uh you know James Worthy there is
[__] you know whoa going like what
the [__] and then they keep talking and
blah blah blah blah and then another
truck goes by and next thing you know
she lost complete control of the car
and as it's spinning right the woman in
the back I think she's pregnant so she's
freaking out oh she's got a baby there
cute little baby is sitting there
you know reading the [__] paper and
they start spinning
so the one in the back the mother is
going hey [__] uh you know Orlando
Woolrich what the [__] what's going on
and as they're spinning the woman behind
the the [__] wheel is gone it's not I
fall it's not my fault it's not my fault
and they [__] they spun into oncoming
traffic
luckily we're not hit right and then
they [__] went off the road into a
ditch and
the big one
the captain captain [__] Kirk took no
responsibility whatsoever
was just like you know and was actually
mad at Old sploochy back there because
she was upset with her she's gonna I I
mean as I as chocolate I was like when
and it it blew me into some black ice
it's like no
you were going too fast you were driving
too [__] fast for those conditions
you lost control of the car
with your niece in the car you [__]
dope
right and
nobody held their fate to the fire
nobody gave her anything it's like you
you are a [__] up
you know just standing there with your
[__] back of your head touching the
top of your back trying to talk to her
get trying to get in a grill right
staring up from her navel looking
between her titties
seeing a half or two nostrils just
yelling at hey you [__] up lady right
none of them said that and then they
just like that they're [__] just
standing there going like
and when my giant eight foot sister lost
control I asked you away
it was like so
guy like they always like build up to a
[__] point you're like yeah and and
it's always just like ha
well in this meteor came down at our
house and it slammed in
to the roof above my bedroom and
for half a second I thought I was gonna
die I was like so
scared
foreign
so I am
standing up
pacing in the living room now like a
[__]
I don't know some [__] pissed off
coach who's trying to stay inside the
coach's box so he doesn't get it
Technical and I'm [__] screaming at
the TV like a bad call was made
completely forgot that I was gonna sit
there and try and get along with my wife
by watching this horseshit and I'm
yelling at the TV I'm like no you
[__] eight foot [__] you [__] up
you were driving too fast fast my
[__] voice cracking you're driving
too
man
Eunice is in the car
right
slow the [__] down you're driving a
four-wheel drive vehicle
you [__] dope oh my God done with
that show
that was it I tried I lasted [__] One
Clip I'm done with that show [__]
done with that show
I [__] hate when people do [__] like
that and people call them on enough
yeah it was your fault it is your fault
stop being powerless you [__]
all right you have total control of that
[__] situation you just drive a
little slower you drive a little
hour
um
anyways
anyway I should be making fun of them
you know what they're going through
right now what they're having to deal
with you know
lefties white black isma up and down is
black and white inside out and now Bruce
is [__] Caitlyn right
I really I I really hold Farm on that
that people cannot get upset with
anybody in that family if they're still
a little [__] wigged out
that their their dad is now their mom
you know what I mean
just exactly what is the average
you know time it takes
you know for you to [__] get your
head around that
you know I don't know my wife's sitting
there going oh he's showing his [__]
titties to his kids it's just like he's
doing what I I mean I don't is that true
if that's true I don't give a [__]
that's just wrong in all kinds of levels
you know what I mean
I know I get it I get it you're coming
back from the mall and you got a little
uh Shoppers High going on and you want
to show what you got but they're tits
right
when you were a guy did you take your
balls out and show them to no you didn't
you don't do that you don't show your
sexual Goods to your [__] kids
and then compile it with new sexual
Goods right and it's not like no one
improved like hey I got my dick enlarged
no
I [__] uh
I got some tits now
would you like to see them no dad I mean
mom I wouldn't
Jesus Christ Caitlyn can you put your
[__] new tits away
is that asking too much
you already took all my Rouge now you're
going to take your tits out
I mean I'm sitting in a car and I shall
I thought it was like so
scar when you took your tits out Dad it
was like that Skye
I was right is my dad taking his tits
out right now
I was like Bruce I mean Kayla I mean
what the [__]
Jesus Christ you know what I mean you
think you haven't I thought I've been
having the weirdest week I don't know
you haven't no you haven't even having a
nice regular [__] time I get news for
you you've been having a time that is
about is that is right is [__] rain
do you understand me
well there you
um anyways what are some of the other
[__] that people want to uh wanted me to
talk about this week
um I don't oh here's another thing I
don't understand like
I get the kids being freaked out by
Caitlyn I get that you know what I mean
I get that they need some time on that
one that makes total [__] sense what
I don't understand is people flipping
out about this white chick who said she
was black
and everybody's going she's actually
white she's saying she's black she's got
on some [__] Tana dude and she
[__] kicked up her hair what the f
like I this is what I don't understand
who gives a [__]
I don't give a [__] if she says she's
Portuguese I don't care
that's what the [__] she wants I I don't
give a [__]
yeah I mean that goes back to Bruce
Jenner I don't give a [__] that he wants
to be a woman but I mean you gotta
understand people gotta whoa hey oh
what's going on here you know you got to
give you got to give people a couple of
weeks
don't call me Katie it's Caitlyn all
right all right sorry sorry
Caitlyn
um
anyways yeah this white chick who said
she was black right
um
the only thing I think was [__] up
out of all of that
Rachel
what's your name which should have been
a dead giveaway have you ever met a
black woman named Rachel
and I got Rachel you look so dope today
oh my God right it's okay man she was
like so fly
um all right Rachel
now that sounds like a black woman's
name her last name she should have
flipped around she said she should have
been dolezel
no doe was there I don't know how to say
it anyways Rachel whatever 37.
was pictured outside of a home Friday
for the first time since the Scandal
erupted over her misrepresentation of
her race this is what people are
flipping out about not that our [__]
food is uh you know
I don't know whatever the [__] they do
with this [__] if they don't tell us
um genetically altered baby seals
washing up onto the [__] beaches [__]
all of that there's some chick from some
[__] god forsaken Place pretending to
be black when she's actually white let's
focus on this
huh
um she also responded to her detractors
in a new interview saying what I'd like
to say to them is I don't give two shits
about what you think I like that there
you go
there you go you go girl
um she then added I do consider myself
to be black her parents revealed
Thursday this is the only thing that I
thought was was [__] up all right her
parents revealed Thursday she started
disguising herself as black in 2007 and
no longer speaks to them because they
will ruin her image
this chick is out of her [__] mind
but in in the long and short of all of
it who is she hurting
you know what I mean
it's as far as a white persons go could
you be any more involved
in in bettering race relations
she killed off the white person inside
of her right she's working at the NAACP
we want more she gonna do on some level
I mean she could have just been
some privileged [__] uh white chick
riding around in a [__] SUV and they
I don't know how it's like that
all right she could have been that
instead
she does all of this [__] but I don't
understand like cutting off your [__]
parents
you know what I mean
I wonder if she called him crackers he
cracked he's got to stay away from my
black ass
[Music]
my newly black ass guess you're gonna
ruin my image she has been a civil
rights activist in Idaho that's not an
easy gig
I remember a long time ago a comic I
knew was working the funny bone up there
and the clan was [__] having a
demonstration in Boise and he called up
the club he was black by the way and
asked for a ride over and they wouldn't
give it to him and they they were like
why do you need a ride it's a quick walk
over he's like I'm cause I'm black and
the clan is having a [__] rally you
[__]
and then the club was just like and I
got why are you being sad
difficult
um
so she was an activist
and uh Idaho
uh she's she also teaches African
studies at Eastern Washington University
and that's a little bit [__] up
you know what I mean
I think she can report on it I don't
know if she can teach about it right or
maybe I guess if you read up enough on
it you can teach the class I have no
idea she is facing a city ethics
investigation after identifying herself
as black in an application to serve on a
local police
Ombudsman commission what the [__]
Ombudsman you know I've been speaking
the English language or at least
attempting to
for 47 [__] year on budsman
definition anybody know does anybody
know
oh ombudsman
an official appointment to investigate
individuals complaints against
Mal Administration
especially that of public authorities
see this is why I don't look up words
now what the [__] is Mal Administration
metal Administration
I have to go to the gynecologist today
to investigate my male Administration my
flow is not where it needs to be sorry
sorry a menstrual flow joke what do you
want from me
um anyway so she's uh I don't know
facing all this [__] Rachel don't
the white NAACP leader
oh my God how much [__] is she gonna get
like now because she's done what she's
done when you see her everyone's just
going to be like hey Whitey
I'm gonna driving nuts
hey cracker
hunky [__]
um
when Brooklyn is this is the fun part
here when they actually interviewed her
somebody asked her say uh what race are
you and she's like um
I don't understand the question and the
guy's like what race are you
okay Rachel whatever she also gave an
interview about the controversy saying
of her attractors I said that already
when pressed further about her race she
told k-r-e-m I actually don't like the
term African-American I prefer black oh
God and I would say that if I was asked
I would definitely say that yes I do
consider myself to be black you know
what I don't understand this you know if
Bruce can consider
him or herself to be Caitlyn why can't
[__] uh Debbie here
consider herself to be uh Desiree
whatever the [__] you want to call her I
don't know Dacia
um
oh my God look at her parents Jesus
Christ
they are extremely White
they're so white her dad's name is Larry
although wait a minute Larry Johnson
played for the Knicks but every time I
hear Larry Larry to me is a white guy
Larry Bird Larry
Jerry
um
Larry and Ruth Ann
oh my God pictured speaking to CNN on
Friday have revealed their daughter
Spokane's NAACP chapter president is
white not African-American
they actually have her [__] birth
certificate
oh man
oh Jesus
you know what is she what the way she's
done her hair
she kind of looks mixed
although when she was a when she was a
little girl she looks like she was on
the ulcers the Olsen's no the [__]
Little House in the prairie hey did
anybody see that [__] article on on
Lionel Richie in GQ Magazine
um
you know at a nine hour flight I [__]
grabbed every magazine out there right
GQ Magazine's such a stupid [__]
magazine by the way they got some decent
articles but what was funny was some guy
in there just ripped Rolling Stones to
shreds
because they [__] you know had the uh
that rape story that ended up not being
true and how they didn't investigate it
saying all this [__] horseshit and
saying that you know I don't even
understand why people took it so
seriously because I oh my God like
Rolling Stone has been relevant forever
right and it's in literally in that GQ
[__] magazine they got who's that
tennis star from [__] Russia the
[__] nine foot blonde who wasn't as
good as Serena but she makes more money
because she's blonde and blue-eyed right
she [__] uh they got her she's she
she's gonna drive some new Porsche right
and the all the quotes that they're
using is that she's [__] totally into
speech she likes driving like a maniac
and she's a car person so I'm like wow
this girl's even hotter now how [__]
hot is it that that uh uh uh some
beautiful woman likes to get behind the
wheel of a Porsche and just [__] see
how fast it can go and the quotes
they're using is leading you to believe
that that's what the [__] going on and
then you read the article and it's like
a one-page article and she's like it's
like I like to go fast but I have too
much to lose by maybe in another life
you know what I mean that's what it was
and you're sitting there talking about
journalistic integrity as you suck me
into this [__] magazine because I
want to read about the new Porsche and
this statues [__] blonde who likes to
drive it like 200 miles an hour that's
the way you sold it you [__] and it
wasn't that
I don't know I don't like that [__]
magazine because they everything
everything in there is like a [__]
thirty thousand dollar watch and you're
supposed to own like a plane like that's
supposed to be the thing that I'm going
for it's like one of my [__] James
Bond like who is this magazine for am I
a spy
I hate when they have [__] pictures
too right and they have a celebrity and
they're [__] in casual clothes and
then they'll be like you know [__] uh
you know Eddie Rickshaw here is where is
wearing uh a [__] 900 t-shirt
by uh whatever that's [__] stores I
always think it's herpes
Hermes right
kind of a [__] jerk off
huh
why would you do you know where's a pair
of [__] 900 mittens
I don't know whatever so I'm off I'm
totally off the beaten path this chick
here wants to be black I mean she should
[__] be uh
her and her parents need to [__] work
on their relationship maybe they can
just
treat it like she's you know
African-American I have no idea like
God knows they live in Idaho they
probably wouldn't let her in the house
they could use the back door and [__]
Larry all mad yeah you wanted to be
blacked as well that's how it is this is
how it is
you were not invited over for Christmas
you can come over and clean up if you
want
right
it'd be [__] hilarious if her parents
were actually [__] racist and then
they start this is like a Chappelle Show
skit waiting to [__] happen
um
so anyways yeah they gotta they
definitely gotta repair some stuff there
I don't know what's going on with this
[__] lady uh
yeah I don't know you know she likes to
go tanning she likes to uh [__]
do her hair up and uh
I don't know what it is if you see the
car she's driving she's definitely a
white chick though
Jesus Christ what is that what the [__]
is that thing
it's one of those things that isn't a
van it isn't an SUV and it isn't a car
you know those things whatever you call
those things
GMC's almost whatever the [__] it is I
don't know
all right whatever God bless her God
bless whatever the [__] she wants to do
you know
um
all right where do you go from here
where do you go from here you know what
you do you read a little bit of
advertising
I think that that's the move to make
here I definitely think that's the move
my white freckled ass thinks that that's
the move to make here
you should definitely do that man I I
would think because I've I've learned in
the last like six months that um when
you actually dress nice as much as your
guy friends break your balls [__]
women love it and I don't mean putting
on a nice goddamn shirt all right I mean
just you know every once in a while you
break out a pocket square
the the level of [__] you're gonna in a
sport coat the level of [__] you're
gonna take from your friends will easily
be balanced out by the amount of [__]
women that will just beg oh my God I
like that look at you
what's going on with you
all right as they slowly drop to their
knees
you know you're getting blown at least
that's how the fantasy Works in my head
my head my head big [__] white
freckled head oh yeah
all right
you see that [__] lady yeah who
yelled at LeBron
he's walking off the court after having
a [__] professional basketball team
on his back for 82 games in four rounds
of the [__] playoffs
you know going head first into a camera
and even needing stitches finishing the
game like a [__] hockey player you'd
think that he'd get respect even though
it is fans of the other team even though
it is an away game
or whatever the [__] it was wasn't away
game I don't know I don't pay attention
so he's walking off the court and some
lady
yells at him
from like 10 feet away she's like hey
LeBron
what's it like to be a punk ass [__]
and I love the security just goes watch
your mouth lady
what's your mom a woman watch your mouth
woman
watch your mouth woman
and LeBron just stopped and glared at
her and I can't tell because everybody
did so many mismatches of the video I
believe she went sorry
you know what is wrong with people
that's one of my favorite Moments in
Sports is when some [__] in the crowd
yells something because you know they're
looking at him like they're a cartoon
all right she wouldn't have said that
[__] to a regular-sized LeBron forget
about what is LeBron six seven six eight
six nine the guy's literally a giant
the guy's a giant oh this was my [__]
voice this week um
I just love when he just stopped and
[__] glared at it but you know what I
mean what do you what would you expect
from a sports fan
from California
all right they they are the worst I am a
huge sports fan and it's depressing how
bad sports fans are in the entire State
of California
the all they every [__] thing they
say ends with the word [__] this is our
house [__] what [__]
[__] Dodgers [__] that just the
[__]
they're the [__] worst
they don't know a [__] thing about
the game and I I know there's gonna be a
bunch of people being like I know about
the game I'm just saying generally
[__] speaking
all right like listen if you actually
said hey Bill you're from Massachusetts
and every time they pan into the crowd
that is those are some of the ugliest
collections of human beings I've ever
seen in in my life I would not argue
with you
all right and I am part of that if I was
in the crowd too I would cause you to
recoil I always see it whenever they go
whenever they pan into the crowd at
Boston I'm always like Jesus Christ look
at those people look at them [__]
animals right
but I'll tell you something about those
animals they know the game and they can
talk the game so can fans in New York oh
well all the East Coast they can [__]
talk the game people in the midwest
great [__] fans
those Maniacs down south but get after
it they can talk about the game I don't
know what the [__] it is
the state of California
you know what's up NBA Finals [__]
this is our house [__] hey LeBron you
punk ass [__] I don't get it
everybody sounds like they're in one of
those awful car movies
right
The Fast and the Furious in 24 seconds
get that car out of here all those
[__] movies Gumball Rally
although they all sound like they're
everybody sounds like they're on [__]
MTV Cribs I don't understand it
I don't know what it is I don't know
what caused it was it reality television
you know what I mean reality television
they had this formula where they would
always have nine annoying white people
and then somebody black and they would
stick them in there and then eventually
the black person lost their [__] mind
because they living with nine white
people
the same way as a white person after a
[__] while you know what I mean the
black person is sitting there and you
know listening to James Taylor in the
background I mean how long do you expect
somebody black to have to deal with that
before they [__] flip out
you know
and I just think watching them screaming
and yelling I noticed over the years all
of a sudden like the [__] white
people on the show
that when they would flip out they
started yelling the way the black person
yelled it was it's been a real weird
thing like when you regardless of your
background
you know what I mean you could be like
you know the whitest like oh my God I
could call this Hawk and everything was
like that now all of a sudden if you
want a reality show and you got into a
fight you'd be like what's up [__] this
is my house [__] your [__] head
would be rolling all around and [__] I
don't I don't [__] get it
but anyways fortunately the only place
in um Sports fandom that that is seeped
into is the California Sports Camp
sports fan the [__] worst
the worst I will say though every once
in a while when you meet a California
sports fan that actually knows the game
it's one of the great it's one of the
great [__] moments that you can have
in this
the state like I stopped going to sports
bars I stopped like if I go to a game I
don't wear any sports paraphernalia
I just don't I don't do I mean look at
what the [__] they did out here they put
goddamn Dodger fans you got a dad with
this with his kids beating to the point
where he's permanently brain damaged
[__] baseball [__] that's just I
don't get it don't [__] get it so it
doesn't surprise me that she said that I
love that LeBron stopped and glared at
her and she was able to be like oh
that's not a [__] hologram that's
actually a real person hologram the
right word
I was like halfway through that
sentences like don't say it Bill don't
say it I'm gonna try a new word I hope
it's right
so anyways um
the [__] uh
Golden State Warriors I actually watched
the game and I watched that kid there
with his chew toy his little pacifier
coming out of his mouth every two
seconds I don't give a [__]
that he does that and it drives me up
the [__] wall that's that is one of
the greatest Shooters of all time I was
actually sitting at the bar
with a body of mine and he was saying
that guy is the greatest shooter in NBA
history and I was like whoa whoa hey oh
wait a minute wait a minute I know he's
having a hell of a year I know he's had
a hell of a couple years I said listen
all right Larry Bird made players from
the opposed he was having a game he was
shooting so well
players on the opposing team when he hit
like his 50th [__] three-pointer of
the game it seemed they fell off the
bench
the coach of the other team had to scold
his players to stop cheering on this guy
who was killing him on the other team
all right so out of respect for Larry
Legend out of respect for Kobe Bryant
I've never seen a guy
have two or three guys hanging on him
from Beyond The Ark and do a turn around
jumper and it [__] goes in more than
that guy however however I will say this
if Curry plays at this level
for the next like for five years
straight without a doubt he's the
greatest shoot I've ever seen in my life
I'd never seen a guy hit threes the way
the guy hits threes
um
I mean I I like Larry Bird Reggie Miller
they've they've had those games but it
just this guy is like unconscious every
[__] game I've never seen anything
like it and watching LeBron
carrying this team I mean I'm not as you
can tell as you can tell I don't really
know this [__] sport but like
watching what that guy's doing with that
team man putting that team on his back
dude like just how much second remember
that guy a few years ago he was that guy
who didn't want the ball at the end of
the game and now he's just
he's this [__] beast and for that
[__] lady to be what's it like to be
a punk ass but what the [__] are you
talking about
uh I wish she'd turn around went to walk
away and he took like his eight foot arm
and just reached and grabbed the back of
her bra I'm like wow right he couldn't
have done that with a center flying over
eight rows but if ever it would have
been deserved
I would think so and um
I have been watching the Stanley Cup
Final
the Stanley Cup Final
um the NBA Finals Stanley Cup Final
um
you know I actually think that somebody
corrects me on that every [__] year
and I was just like I'm just at that old
age now I'm just like oh I said oh I say
it
um I've been watching that one and uh I
think the Blackhawks
winning that game five just won the
series going back to Chicago that's
really not I'm not going out on a limp
but this that amazing thing when you see
a truly great team
that's going to win a number of
championships their ability to step up
in the moments and their ability
to know how to win a game that's lost
they stole that [__] game five
no no they didn't all the time they
stole that game four was even when they
stole I think they stole game four game
five game five was when the [__]
Tampa just kept [__] up on their own
end
they [__] the goalie and the
defenseman run into each other
they look like Peewee hockey
and they had so many giveaways in their
own [__] end I just I don't know
I bet as a Tampa fan your heart had to
sink when that [__] happened
considering every goddamn game has been
a one goal game that the fact that you
give up an easy one like that you must
be thinking that that's like being down
like three goals in this series but
anyways it's been an amazing thing and
if uh
if uh Chicago wins three in the last six
years man I would say that they are the
new Detroit Red Wings and I mean that is
the highest compliment because the Red
Wings had that run
for like 10 11 years where every time
you thought you know there's Stars okay
eiserman's getting old all right this is
done they just have that next [__]
Superstar step in
and uh they just [__] knew how to win
and uh I don't I'm a big fan of
dynasties
I like I like seeing like um I don't
like this team wins next year this team
wins next team this team wins like you
you need you need dynasties
so you have like that uh those Timeless
players you know what I mean like as
much as people you know
who who play against the Blackhawks all
the [__] time say like Vancouver fans
who probably hate the [__] Blackhawks
right or Minnesota fans St Louis Blues
fans as much as you hate them you gotta
you gotta admit even now
Jonathan tapes he's the [__] man you
have to I don't give a [__] I don't give
a [__] if you bleed your [__] team's
colors you just
so anyways I'm gonna watch that game
tonight and I actually think that um
Chicago closes them out however I am
going to be rooting for Tampa because I
don't have a dog in this [__] fight
and I don't want the hockey season to
end I'd like it to go seven games
um and by the way I think this has been
the best NBA finals in Stanley Cup
finals like in the same year in a long
time and it's been [__] great so I'm
glad I'm back in the country here
where I can actually uh watch this shite
um and speaking of which
oh am I going to go to the I'm not gonna
go to these yet did anybody see Hillary
Clinton's [__] speech when she went
up there dressed in Democrat blue
oh my God at the risk of burning a bit
because I'm definitely going to talk
about this
to sit there and watch her
talking about rich people
when her and her husband go to that
Bilderberg [__] meeting every year
where the world's richest [__] people
most powerful military people and most
powerful political people all get
together and decide how they're going to
carve up the country the [__] world
this year
she's at that [__] meeting and she's
sitting there talking about the Working
Man
as touchy doesn't work
if you guys can't work
whatever the [__] she said
I'm gonna get you guys some jobs and
everybody's like yeah
yeah you dumb little flag
I I don't
she's literally making fun of the super
rich and it's like Hillary how are you
going to get into office
you were a senator what does that pay a
couple hundred grand a year this [__]
job costs 100 million to get
costs 100 million to get to then make
like 400 Grand a year as president
right how the [__] are you going to get
that job
from what regular Joe's 25 contribution
to your [__] campaign
or these [__] [__] the rich the
exact Rich [__] that you're talking
about is how you're going to be [__]
president you're going to owe all of
them favors
and you're gonna do exactly what the
[__] they tell you so you can get a
second term and then in the end
when your [__] presidency is over
you're then going to go around the
country and give speeches for a million
dollars a night nobody's worth a million
a night but you're gonna get paid a
million dollars a night and you're gonna
go right back speaking to the people who
put you into [__] office and they're
going to give you a million dollars is
they don't even [__] listen to you
right because they don't give a [__] all
they're doing is washing their bribe
money and okay
if you can't [__] see that
and you're gonna sit there and vote for
a democrat or a republican I can't I
can't even have a [__] conversation
with you and you people who sit there
and say if you vote for the libertarian
[__] guy or whatever that you throw
in your vote away I I you're not
you're not
all you're gonna get it doesn't make a
difference who wins the Democrat or the
Republican you're going to get the exact
same [__] [__] sandwich it might be a
little to the left a little to the
[__] right but it's going to be the
exact same [__] sandwich because those
Rich [__] have money on both horses so
no matter what they win right
so
the [__] if you vote for somebody
outside of that all you're doing is
encouraging more people
that there's hope that you can maybe
somehow undo this [__] situation
I don't know I actually think that it's
it's [__] over I don't think that
it's
it's possible you know it's it's so
[__] depressing though to watch
people once again
once again I'm gonna sit there and
listen to a candidate who's a Democrat
or Republican make these stupid ass
[__] promises and they lose their
[__] minds thinking that it's
actually going to change their lives for
the better
you know I I don't I don't know sorry I
know that's [__] super depressing
that's just what I think so anyways
let's get into the uh the questions here
for the week
all right and if you listen to these
questions I'm gonna get Joe six pack of
[__] Jack
um all right French listeners
hey Bill I thought I'd let you know we
appreciate your acts and think you're
doing a good job I live in Paris France
oh [__] look at this
and yes you're right we're mostly
[__] to people whether they come for
France
um or abroad and I don't think you guys
are [__] you guys treated me nice uh
currently with a couple of friends
having a good time listening to your
rant slash jokes and since I've been
following you for a few months I said to
myself let the guy know you enjoy his
jokes well I appreciate that so there
you have it you have to come to you have
some French listener idiots over here
that enjoy your show please keep it up
have a drink with some French people at
some point and go [__] yourself at
another
well I I'll tell you I I'm gonna do a
show in France at some point actually I
already talked to my um
to my agent about it
um
there was a theater over in the uh the
Sea Salad
um I think it was called the Odeon
the Odeon theater
there's a stop called the Odeon on the
Metro this is a theater the Odeon
theater in uh in Paris and gay Patty
um there it is Odeon theater
it's a [__] 800 Cedar
how do you say that how do you say 800
in France in French
wheat salt
is what it is
wait a minute remember I [__]
see-song
that's what song
is I don't [__] I can't [__] remember
um
you gotta listen to French talk radio I
love that because over here when you
listen to the English ones they're going
like
um
um two two two two two two do what you
need to do here don't you see you have
to
um
um ah like you know that [__] dragon
and I was you trying to
come up with your thoughts right put
your thoughts together over there they
go like
[__] I'm telling you you smoke a
joint you listen to that [__] you're
gonna [__] laugh your ass off
um so anyways
the Odeon theater is it's located at
in the Sea Salad of Patty on the Left
Bank of the sun next to Luxembourg
Garden
um oh yeah I know where that is I just
love that I know where that is it was
originally built between 1779 and 1782.
right back before particle board nail
guns took you a little while to build
something in the garden at the former
Hotel uh to a neoclassical blah blah
blah the theater was inaugurated wait a
second this is what I love here
it was reopened in eight it burned in
1818 everything [__] burned down back
then it was all made out of wood you
didn't have any fire hydrants and some
jerk off comes in and drops his
cigarette down Sacrament throws the
[__] thing down all of a sudden
and everybody's just like run for your
lives right
and the whole thing [__] burns down
they got the Bucket Brigade
trying to pee on the Fire
then they just like God damn it all
right let's rebuild it and they start
all over again
that's why they were in great shape back
then
be building and rebuilding of [__] that
burned down in their [__] food wasn't
uh genetically altered
that right there that is a recipe
for a six-pack so anyways that is my
goal I want to do a show there
Nia's already given me [__] you know
because I'm a [__] workaholic and
she's giving me [__] going like can that
just be like the one city where you know
we just hang out
you know we have some us time you know
which she's so [__] right
but I'm a guy so I'm gonna [__] that up
I thought I finally got it I think I
finally get being in a relationship
and um
how to keep a woman happy believe it or
not
um
I think I finally get it
I don't know how to explain it to you
because it's like embarrassing because
it involves feelings and listening and
being respectful
[Music]
um and all you women right now who went
like you see that's a two-way street
all right it's a [__] two-way street
so anyways
um
I don't give a [__] I'm still gonna play
over that come on man to have a show in
Paris if AC DC can play in Paris you
know what I mean they can't you know
there's no [__] way I can sit there
and not want to play that place
I love AC DC
you know
Pon Scott one of his last [__] shows
he plays in Paris I gotta I gotta [__]
it I don't give a [__] if count on
people [__] show up
right I don't give a [__] I'm gonna do
it
I'll be like look it's one [__] show
it's one show she'll give it she's a
sweetheart
um so anyways that's nice I got I
actually got some letters here from
people from France and they're actually
helping me with my French all right the
French correction from a lady
that's [__] great hey Billy boy I'm
I'm listening to your last Thursday
afternoon Monday Morning podcast and I
have to correct you about your French
insults Oh by all means
I don't want to be like Roman Maroney
you [__] bastard just that's a
[__] twit question
the next one of you Fargo nice host that
something remember that he's gonna have
his [__] Bells his [__] bells in
his sling you cork sucker Jesus the
mouth on that guy
um Roman moroni's one of my favorite
characters of all time it's in uh Johnny
dangerously he's an immigrant and he uh
he has a potty mouth but he
mispronounces all of the curses so I
don't wanna I don't want to be the Roman
Maroney
of uh France so anyways
she says I'm listening to your last
Thursday afternoon uh Monday Morning
podcast just before Friday just yeah and
I have to correct you about your French
insults if you want to say [__] your
mother we usually say
I'm really nervous about
n-i-q-u-e-r like that could be like I
could accidentally say the n-word there
or say something homophobic because the
end kind of looks like queer
Nick where
[Music]
Amir
you gotta help me out can you sound
spell that so I don't [__] it up say
that instead of baser is preferred here
um
about this is [__]
about something a better translation
will be uh say de la mer this is [__] I
like that better than this is [__]
this is [__] you're getting right to it
say that I'm mad
hey Jacques said
um
um rather than saying
Connery Connery can be can be employed
when you want to say to someone what you
say is [__] and the translation is
to rec to recante De conare I know I
stink I got to get the Rosetta Stone
here
uh and and the last one
uh employed very employed in France
let's see look at that giant too they're
[__] up the English here I guess this
means used a lot in France
um
hope I'm saying that first word right
which I'm probably not when the person
in front of you is the biggest [__]
that you've ever met in your life
what does it mean
Ard is that pig you [__] pig does
that means you're an [__]
oh there's two wins I don't know well
thank you Sabrina hey by the way you
guys anybody French listening to this if
you can help me out with anything just
like uh
we're going to brunch I learned that
yesterday right we were going to go to
brunch
because I had like you know I'm trying
to [__] be a better husband here so
I'm just like all right this is your
ESPN Sports Zone let's go to [__]
brunch
and um
oh my God what a [__] show
brunch is the dumbest [__] thing ever
let's go to breakfast when everybody
else is going to breakfast so we can all
you just you just see these [__]
people
as you're driving over there all these
breakfast places but you're not going to
them and you just see all of these
people just standing outside sitting on
benches staring at their [__] iPhones
you know what I mean and considering
breakfast is the easiest [__] meal to
make you can't scramble up some eggs
yourself
while your wife makes some pancakes you
can go make yourself a grand slam
breakfast you guys can sit around right
somebody's got the orange juice you got
some music playing and guess what
there's a table
the kitchen table no waiting right but
that's not what they want to do you want
to [__] go out everybody look at
their outfits everybody look at the
[__] outfits um
so anyways all right so there we got one
from Manchester England here Manchester
England Bill I'm a big fan from across
the pond as you Yankees like to say uh
not Yankees Yanks
don't call us Yankees all right I'm Red
Sox you understand me I was wondering if
you I was wondering if you ever consider
filming a special obsessed preferably in
England thanks for the laugh [__] [__]
you [__] everybody laughs every
miserable account of
oh that thing used to go
don't make me laugh every count with a
long face
um
would I ever consider doing a special
overseas
um
yeah I was actually considering doing
one in France just doing it in French
and just putting the [__] thing out
and then I could actually do the same
one in English somewhere else I'd have
two different [__] specials
I wouldn't give a [__] if a bunch of
them English-speaking countries saw the
French one they're not even going to
know what I'm talking about
because they don't speak French for the
most part and that's the way we get a
little two for one there
you know what I mean right there like
right there the way I'm thinking
comedically is I am thinking the Way
Home Depot thinks like how can we take
those two employees make them one and
get the same job done and we make more
[__] money that's what I'm doing
you know I'm being a bit of a being
being a little shaky
um when I consider doing one over there
um
I don't know
I don't know if I get you guys enough
that uh
that I would do that I would I would
tell you this though I really enjoyed
doing one
last last time
down south I think what everybody seems
to like to do is to get in front of
their own people
um because you don't want to get heckled
or anything but I think there's there's
some fun
that is lost
when uh you stand up in front of a room
that's all you you know what I mean I
think you want a little back and forth
personally like I've always enjoyed
you know people yelling out to me I
don't I'm more I don't give a [__] if
somebody yells out to me I mean if
you're just being an [__] and just
trying to disrupt the [__] show
obviously that's annoying but
I say a lot of stupid [__] on stage so
it doesn't surprise me
you know when I'm talking about the wage
Gap that some woman yells at me when I'm
in the crowd and then to be honest with
you I really want to hear what she has
to say because I'm trying to learn
something about it because I don't have
to deal with that [__] and the only way
I can hear that is through my own
[__] manners
so it's good to hear her [__]
perspective so I don't consider that a
Heckle I consider it a conversation so
getting back to that to go to England I
would probably say some [__]
deliberately to get you guys going
because what's the fun what the [__] is
the purpose of me going over to England
if I'm not going to give you guys a
little bit of [__] and then you give me
a little [__] back and then we all
[__] laugh right so maybe that could
be a good idea sir
that might be a good idea I don't know I
would I would definitely consider it
I would consider it you know I'd run
that up the flagpole all right let me do
the last little bits of uh advertising
here
and uh and then I'll answer your last
questions you guys can get on with your
life all right stamps.com everyone
making trips to the post office is
becoming a thing of the past you just
don't need to do it anymore thanks to
stamps.com you already know that going
to the post office is inconvenient yeah
but you know if you're into collecting
stamps or if you want some cool stamps
you know what I mean feel one of those
nerds you know if you're into that like
bird watching you'd probably still go to
the post office but for the rest of you
you already know that going to the post
office is it's a nightmare totally
inconvenient driving there right
standing behind the person who's trying
to send a muffler out in a [__]
envelope right you don't want to be
there finding partying waiting in line
the whole damn thing but you probably
didn't know is you're paying more for
postage there than you have to
stamps.com is the better way
buying print official U.S postage for
any letter any package right from your
computer or printer then just hand it to
the mailman hey how are you Skippy
thanks for not shooting me bye bye
Postman uh with stamps.com you'll get
special postage discounts you can't even
get at the post office on First Class
Priority Mail International and more
never go to the post office again hey
everybody I use stamps.com to send out
all my posters
all of my posters for my tours uh right
now use my last name Burr for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to 55 free posters don't
wait go to stamps.com before you do
anything else click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
Burr that stamps.com enterberg and by
the way for all you guys who ordered the
autograph posters they've all been
they're they're been
put in their tubes and they're being
shipped out this week
um I want to thank everybody for buying
those getting those out of my house uh I
still got a few more left over in some
box but uh I have some leftover posters
also from um my run of 19 shows at the
uh at the Wilbur in Boston and uh got a
couple hundred of those left over
autographed all of those and we'll
probably in the next month put those
back up on the website
um
um just so we can get we gotta get all
the other ones shipped out first all
right if you're wondering where your
poster is it's on the way all right
LegalZoom everyone
there's a lot of great reasons that
smart people trust uh legalism for
starters if you want to incorporate form
an LLC or non-profit file a patent or a
trademark get a DBA and more LegalZoom
provides the help you need over the past
decade more than a million businesses
business owners just like you have
started with LegalZoom but did you know
that LegalZoom is also your first step
when you need advice from a first stop
when you need advice from an attorney
LegalZoom is not a law firm so they
built a network of independent attorneys
in Most states to provide legal advice
and other useful services to help you
run your business so whether you need a
contract reviewed or advice or whether
you should incorporate a form an LLC
whatever your legal question is start
with legalism and as always they provide
complete transparency with upfront
pricing customer reviews and 100
satisfaction guaranteed make the Smart
Choice go for your business make the
smart choice for your business at
legalzoom.com today and don't forget to
enter Burr at checkout to save even more
again that's Burr Burr at checkout for
more savings LegalZoom promo code Burr
legal help is here
um and lastly but not leastly if you'd
like to uh
donate to the podcast and it won't cost
you anything next time you go into
amazon.com to buy something swing by
billboard.com first click on the merch
page click on the Amazon link it'll take
you right to Amazon it doesn't cost you
any extra money they just kicked me a
little uh little something something for
[__] driving traffic to their site
all right do it if you want to if you
don't I understand you're a busy person
you don't got time to be doing extra
clicks do you all right let's get on
with the last questions here
dilemma Billy Bird
would you rather play 15 seasons in a
professional sport and win zero Rings or
win one year rookie year and suffer a
career-ending injury the next
oh oh Jesus uh no I'll take the 15
Seasons I'll take the money and put the
rest on a gift certificate no I would
rather uh as much as you want to win a
championship there's also Playing For
the Love of the Game you know and
there's also uh
I think I think
I think most athletes
would choose playing 15 seasons
because you want to play
you know you also if you're gonna [__]
up your body
I don't want just one [__] you know
what kind of contract did I get my
rookie year
I mean if I had a [__] contract and I
was on that team and I got my ring and
then I blow out my knee the next year
I'm working at the [__] I'm doing
landscaping
and people like hey yeah you you you
were you played in the Super Bowl and I
look at you trimming hedges
you know that would be a [__]
you know it would take a while
to get over that emotionally
um
you know like I bet you know what's his
face there for the Broncos I was at the
game too when he suffered his
career-ending injury
um Tyrell Davis I was at that ever tell
you guys that I was at that game I was
doing some college gigs out in um
Colorado
and uh as always I always try to build
the road around something you know
beyond just doing stand-up so you know
you you get a feel for that part of the
country and one of the big things for me
was always going to sporting events so
this was they were still in Mile High
Stadium they had just won back-to-back
titles John Elway retired
right I always wanted to play one more
year if they could have got three but
you know Terrell got hurt but what if
Terrell got hurt if John was playing
what do they have passed on that play
who knows anyway so they were playing
the Jets j-e-t-s and uh that's when Bill
Parcells was there and he was building a
monster
and they were going to win their first
Super Bowl they were favorites one of
the favorites to go to the Super Bowl at
the beginning of the year so I uh you
know one I saw
that they were going to be playing the
Denver Broncos in Mile High Stadium like
the fifth week of the Season or
something like that and lo and behold
John Elway is not playing it was
supposed to be at this great [__]
matchup the Broncos were all in four the
Jets that year uh Vinnie Testaverde blew
out his Achilles 10 in the first game of
the year
that's when Keyshawn cried right there's
nobody give me the damn ball
um no that's my quarterback was that
other guy they're not a lunatic that's
my quarterback you don't talk about it
that's my quarterback
um
so the Jets were owing four so it was
two [__] Owen four teams and I showed
up and there was like nobody there the
scalpers had a mountain of [__] take
I bought a ticket for [__] uh face
value I could have probably got it for
less but you know I'm not one of those
people it's like all right dude you'll
break even here you go give you [__]
money and I went to the game and um
and that was the game at Terrell Davis
uh unfortunately
one of the would have been I still think
he is one of the great [__] running
backs of all time
and uh I mean I can't imagine what that
guy had to go through emotionally after
winning two rings
and just wondering what might have been
I think despite winning the
Championships and knowing what that
feels like
I think the the equal to that high would
be
the low of what could have been
and you know and when he's watching all
of those uh greatest running backs of
all time he's left off that list a lot
because he doesn't have because what
people do in those arguments is they
immediately go to the almanac and they
go all right Emmett Smith has 17 000
[__] yards
you know they look Dickerson Walter
Payton [__] Jim Brown O.J Simpson
they go through all of those guys and
they're looking because their career
numbers are up there and then guys who
got hurt
um Barry Sanders
you know Barry Sanders
who would I think is the greatest
running back of all time the greatest
one that I ever saw
um
I would say the most complete I ever saw
was Walter Payton
I'd say the most devastating
just
of speed and Power
that was a precursor to Beau Jackson was
Earl Campbell
Bo Jackson was like a faster
but I would say not as strong as Earl
Campbell
that's how big Earl Campbell was by the
way
um
Bo Jackson
and Barry Sanders
I would say those four
were the best that I ever saw and but
then as far as just effortless the
greatest just most beautiful Runner I
ever saw was Eric Dickerson Eric
Dickerson didn't even look like he had
to try he just looked like he was just
he looked like he was jogging and he did
you couldn't even you couldn't
understand why people couldn't catch up
to him
ah man that just makes me [__] it that
that that was football back then I
[__] I dude I that's the greatest
thing do you realize I grew up
you know started watching sports in the
late 70s and I got to see all of the
late 70s in the 80s like the Golden Age
of football was in the 70s I got to see
the end of that and then the result of
it the West Coast offense air Coryell
all of that Dan Marino and all those
guys come of age in the 80s all those
great running backs and meanwhile in
hockey you had [__]
Wayne Gretzky Mario Lemieux those great
Edmonton teams uh um the Mystique of the
Canadians was was still there
um I'm not insulting Canadian fans like
it just
the big bad [__] Bruins it just it
just was [__] amazing perfect amount
of the greatest goal scorers of all time
[__] Paul Coffey scored like 49 50
goals as a [__] defenseman
was unbelievable and then there was
always a fight like every like period
period and a half it was [__] perfect
and then in basketball you had Larry
Bird
Magic Johnson that then went into
[__] Michael Jordan
this is just the [__] 80s
and baseball was the one that actually
kind of dropped off
during that time but even though they
dropped off you still had the wizard of
Ozzy Smith
you still like Kirk Gibson's home run
you still had the bash Brothers in the
the Oakland a'sh right
Yankees dropped off or whatever but it
was still great
still still [__] great that's like
the 80s might be the greatest decade
ever if you were just a [__] sports
fan an American Sports to watch I'm
arguing that right now I'm saying it
might have been the greatest one it
might have been
um all right Walmart fight a billy
birthday boy how are you
happy belated birthday thank you very
much just wanted to share with you what
I believe to be the finest display of
white trash entertainment found on the
internet
this video has gone viral and where I uh
where I live and it's not every day you
see two obese fat [__] duking it out in
a Walmart
um it's two women I've actually seen
this uh
this video and um
let's see what does it say I'm sorry I
was just making sure that it wasn't in
mono again
my headphones felt weird here for a
second uh this video has gone viral
around where I live
um the lady does bring her kid in off
the sideline at one point so I guess we
can call it a family outing anyways just
thought you'd have a chuckle and you and
your podcast last Thursday June 11th was
one of the greatest ones thank you I
mean stitches make you all right thank
you um yeah I did see this and I
actually
loved
I know what this says about me I loved
that that little kid took out the
shampoo bottle
you know and was helping out his mom
you know what is the kid supposed to
[__] do like that is exactly a mom's
losing the fight
you got to jump in there and save your
mom
I mean even if you don't love your mom
that's your ride home you [__] seven
years old
so he goes to take the [__] he grabs a
shampoo bottle dude it was like
wrestling back in the day Captain Lou
Albano comes in with the foreign object
oh and the ref didn't see it I guess
people got upset because some were
telling the kid not to do it
and then one woman was saying telling
the kid to do it and I agreed with her
because if you're just gonna stand there
and you're not going to break up the
fight
you know
I don't know at that point I think
everybody's guilty at that point I
actually thought it was great and I
actually thought that that kid could
have swung the bottle a little harder I
would have liked to seen that kid get a
little more torque
he needed to twist his butt he went more
with like Hammer fist motion which I
understand because UFC is really popular
but
um you know if he got one of those
one of those baseball videos you know
how to swing a bat correctly you know
they broke it down into the three
[__] movements if he got that thing
going on uh he would have knocked her
out I just love that one of them drives
up in like one of those [__] Motor
Cars because they can't [__] walk
so you're thinking like oh maybe you
have some sort of disease maybe you're
you're paralyzed I don't know what the
[__] going on with you but uh you know
I respect that you're in that thing and
I'm gonna get out of the way and all of
a sudden she [__] stands up like some
preacher put his hand on her forehead
it turns out she's fine
and she's fighting and [__] so it really
came that that was the most fascinating
thing to me it's like so why are you in
that motorized car
are you just [__] lazy
or are you a genius
because I got to admit you ever seen
those motorized cards those things can
[__] fly
and there is an expression why stand up
when you can sit down why sit down when
you can lie down
why walk when you can drive
you know all you got to do is lay off
the donuts and you're crushing it
um
anyways I don't know what to tell you
all right that's the podcast for this
[__] week I'll put the link up
for that
um I don't have any any crazy
predictions for the finals I think that
they're gonna go
the way that they're gonna go
you know I think Chicago is going to win
the cup and I think uh Sacramento is
going to win the title
I'm happy for the [__] Warriors man
if they win and I'll be happy for the
Cavaliers if they [__] win
um I really like both of those teams
both those organizations and stuff I
just like them you know what I mean
neither one of us wanted for [__]
ever you really can't if you're a true
sports fan
you know you got to be happy for either
one
um and then as far as uh the Stanley Cup
goes I'd love to see Tampa win because
I'm a huge Steve Eiserman fan and um I
just I've said this before I just like
Tampa in general I like the devil race I
still call them the devil race [__]
[__] down there
if we say Devil Rays does that mean that
we lock the devil can we just calm the
race I mean I'm getting nervous [__] I
live on a houseboat I'll ride out in
Clearwater Florida I'm just a regular
man I don't think I don't think for
myself I think if you say a word that
means this this Damon's gonna come out
come right up